[Música]
el papá francisco llegó a canadá donde
pedirá perdón por los abusos cometidos
por la iglesia católica contra
comunidades indígenas entre los siglos
19 y 20 en silla de ruedas francisco fue
recibido en medio de actos de
comunidades nativas
jair bolsonaro aspira a la reelección el
presidente brasileño lanzó oficialmente
su candidatura a los comicios de octubre
durante un evento en río de janeiro el
mandatario atacó al sistema electoral al
poder judicial y al expresidente luiz
ignacio lula da silva
al menos 17 migrantes haitianos murieron
en las costas de bahamas luego de que
naufragara el bote en el que se
transportaban decenas de ellos al
parecer con destino a miami las
autoridades investigan un presunto
contrabando de personas
hola bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano los saluda andrés
meza muñoz empezamos en canadá el papá
francisco llegó este domingo al país y
donde permanecerá hasta el 30 de julio
el motivo de su visita es pedir perdón a
los indígenas canadienses por los más de
150 mil niños sacados de sus hogares así
como el descubrimiento de más de 200
menores enterrados en una escuela a
continuación a mal benotman con los
detalles de las reivindicaciones de los
nativos los pueblos indígenas de canadá
esperaban esta visita desde hace años el
papá francisco aterrizó este domingo en
el país tengamos cuidado en este viaje
lo que como he dicho es un viaje de
penitencia digamos que ese su espíritu
se espera que francisco se reúna con
representantes de las primeras naciones
que exigen sus excusas por los abusos a
miles de niños indígenas entre 1880 y
1990 frank supone
la disculpa del papá francisco es un
reconocimiento del papel de la iglesia
en el daño y el dolor causado a los
pueblos indígenas que viven
para algunos de los nuestros la disculpa
el papá francisco no será suficiente la
curación no es lineal esta disculpa será
un paso fundamental hacia el perdón el
cierre la curación y la reconciliación
para muchos otros
el 27 de mayo de 2021 especialistas
contratados por representantes indígenas
descubrieron los restos de 215 niños en
el antiguo internado de kamloops en la
columbia británica la conmoción en todo
el país fue inmensa en total durante el
verano de 2021 más de 1300 tumbas de
niños indígenas fueron encontradas estos
descubrimientos aceleraron la conciencia
del vaticano sobre la necesidad de dar
un paso y confirmó las conclusiones de
la comisión de la verdad y la
reconciliación y en 2015 expuso el
maltrato y los abusos sistemáticos
sufridos por los niños de las primeras
naciones
el informe hablaba de genocidio cultural
y calculaba que habían muerto al menos
3.200 niños esta cifra sea luego
reevaluado en más de 6000 en su informe
la comisión pidió una disculpa del papa
a los supervivientes sus familias y sus
comunidades por el papel de la iglesia
católica romana
vamos a brasil el presidente ya er
bolsonaro lanzó oficialmente su
candidatura a la reelección de cara a
los comicios de octubre en los que
enfrentará al ex mandatario luiz inácio
lula da silva la más reciente encuesta
de la agencia data fall ya divulgada en
junio mostró en la delantera al
candidato izquierdista frente a
bolsonaro quien ha planteado reiteradas
dudas sobre la confiabilidad del sistema
electoral brasileño
jair bolsonaro va oficialmente por la
reelección en un discurso frente a más
de 10.000 personas en un evento que da
como inicio oficial a su candidatura
voy a continuar en medio del pueblo pase
lo que pase
[Aplausos]
este es un país cristiano es un país de
valores es un país del presente y del
futuro
en su búsqueda de ganar adeptos
bolsonaro ha destacado los logros del
gobierno para garantizar la libertad
religiosa y económica y sus esfuerzos
para no dejar que el comunismo triunfé
en el país pero su gobierno con una
cuestionada gestión ambiental por el
aumento de la deforestación amazónica un
turbulento manejo de la pandemia y con
una elevada inflación parecía haber
cansado a la mayoría de brasileños la
más reciente encuesta de la agencia de
atacó la publicada en junio ubica a
bolsonaro a 19 puntos porcentuales de su
principal rival el ex presidente
izquierdista luiz inácio lula da silva
sin ser te las opciones de un triunfo
jair bolsonaro ha asegurado
reiteradamente y sin ofrecer pruebas que
el sistema electrónico electoral de
brasil utilizado desde 1996 se presta
para fraude una acusación que hizo en
frente de 60 embajadores internacionales
y que según la constitución del país
representa un crimen de responsabilidad
por atentar contra los poderes
constitucionales los fueros tenemos un
sistema electoral que sólo dos países en
el mundo utilizan no es un sistema
confiable porque no puede ser auditado
es imposible hacer una auditoría en las
elecciones aquí en brasil
tan sólo tres meses antes de las
elecciones evolucionaron también logró
sacar adelante su paquete de ayudas en
el que planea repartir siete mil 650
millones de dólares en subsidios una
medida que según expertos de economía
avivar a la inflación de dos dígitos y
dañará el tipo de cambio de brasil la
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales de brasil se celebrará el
2 de octubre
17 migrantes haitianos perdieron la vida
luego de que el bote en el que viajaban
naufragara cerca de bahamas y en el que
se cree pretendían llegar a miami la
guardia costera bahameña logró rescatar
a 25 personas y se está llevando a cabo
una investigación multiagencial para
determinar todas las circunstancias que
rodean una presunta operación de
contrabando de personas
una tragedia en el mar al menos 17
personas murieron después de que una
embarcación que transportaba decenas de
inmigrantes haitianos se volcará a unas
7 millas de la isla de nueva providencia
en las bahamas aumentó entre esos
números hay 16 mujeres 15 mujeres
adultas y un niño pequeño por desgracia
que parecía tener entre 4 y 5 años y un
hombre juana mail
los equipos de salvamento también
rescataron a 25 personas entre las 60
que podrían haber estado a bordo de
acuerdo con el primer ministro de
bahamas philip davies las autoridades
bahameñas presumen que hay más
desaparecidos
asimismo informaron que dos personas
fueron detenidas ambas de bahamas por la
presunta operación de contrabando de
personas
en la medida en que esas investigaciones
se revelen culpabilidad penal no habrá
ni alguna resistencia por parte del
gobierno de las bahamas para emprender
las acciones penales necesarias y la
aplicación de la ley penal contra
aquellos que lo merezcan
sus organizo las bahamas son una ruta de
tránsito frecuente para los haitianos
que quieren llegar a eeuu los peligrosos
viajes por mar en embarcaciones en mal
estado se han hecho cada vez más
frecuentes en el último año debido a la
pobreza y a la creciente violencia de
las pandillas criminales en haití el
pasado mayo 11 personas se ahogaron
cuando una embarcación con migrantes
haitianos se volcó cerca de puerto rico
en eeuu las autoridades continúan
luchando para apagar el incendio
en el parque nacional de yosemite y que
se ha convertido en uno de los más
grandes del año impulsadas por el calor
extremo que ha sufrido este el este del
país las llamas habían consumido más de
5.700 hectáreas hasta este domingo unas
3000 personas fueron obligadas a evacuar
pero pronto podrían ser unas 5000 las
causas del incendio continúan bajo
investigación
y en otras noticias de eeuu los
fanáticos de la ciencia ficción se
reunieron durante cuatro días para
celebrar el comic-con de san diego un
evento que muestra lo mejor de la
cultura geek elaborados disfraces y
anuncios de nuevas películas fueron los
protagonistas en esta convención que se
realizó nuevamente luego de tres años de
cancelaciones por la pandemia andrés
triviño nos amplia
los fanáticos de los cómics y la ciencia
ficción cumplieron sus fantasías en el
comic-con de san diego durante cuatro
días los asistentes del evento mostraron
sus disfraces más llamativos inspirados
en sus personajes favoritos del cine los
videojuegos y la televisión todos somos
fanáticos y la idea que te puedas
acercar un poco más al personaje que
estás enamorado o con el que te
relacionas viendo la televisión te hace
sentir vídeo
siento que es una excelente manera de
poder expresarse mediante un personaje o
una película que apreciamos
en el evento al que también asistieron
panelistas y expertos se anunciaron
diferentes novedades y exclusivas sobre
los próximos estrenos de películas de
ciencia ficción este año black panther y
una nueva edición del señor de los
anillos' fueron las protagonistas el
evento volvió a realizarse luego de tres
años en los que la pandemia forzará su
cancelación alrededor de 130.000
asistentes tuvieron que mostrar una
prueba coach negativa para entrar al
centro de eventos de san diego
oh dios mío es lo mejor hemos estado en
las trincheras del cob y haciendo una
película durante más de dos años y ahora
podemos mostrar esto directamente a los
fans los fans que son los mejores el
comic-con de san diego se celebra desde
1970 fue fundado por un grupo de amantes
de las caricaturas y desde entonces es
el evento más importante de este tipo en
eeuu
hasta aquí este informativo en francés
24 gracias por acompañarnos continúan
con toda nuestra programación
[Música]